مشاهدينا نعود لمتابعه هذه الصور المباشره
لعمليات تمشيط الجيش الاسرائيلي في منطقه
غور الاردن هذه الصور المباشره للمنطقه
التي تم فيها اطلاق نار على مستوطنات
اسرائيليات قتلت اثنتين
واصيبه الثالثه اصابات خطيره قبل اكثر من
ساعه مشاهدينا اكد الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه
المعلومه وقال ان انه يمشط منطقه الاغوار
بحثا عن منفذ اطلاق نار الدنمارك
لمستوطنتين واصابه الثالثه بجروح خطيره
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه ايضا اكد ان
الجيش ما زال يطارد
المنفي الاول المنفذين ومراسل العربيه اكد
ان رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلياهو يجري مشاوره امنيه مع كبار
المسؤولين الامنيين بعد عمليه اطلاق النار
هذه في اغوار الاردن
ونتابع مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره اذا
نلاحظ فيها
قوات الجيش الاسرائيلي التي تطوق هذا
المكان وتقوم بالاجراءات واجراءات التعقب
ايضا والتمشيط لمنفذ او منفذ هذه العمليه
قامت ايضا القوات الاسرائيليه
باغلاق المنافذ في اريحا وفي نابلس منعا
لهروب منفذ او منفذي هذه العمليه بعض
المصادر تحدثنا عن ان
تضرر سياره منفذ العمليه دفعته الى
التحرك والتنقل في هذه المنطقه السيره على
الاقدام لذلك هناك اجراءات كبيره وجهود
تبذلها قوات الاسرائيليه لمطارده والقاء
القبض على هذا المنفذ وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه ايضا مشاهدينا افادت بان وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي سيعقد اجتماعا مع كبار
المسؤولين لتقييم الوضع الامني